I've seen you at Wango Tango you saw
Taylor Swift there here we are jingle
ball core you know she got here but who
are you excited to see tonight oh gosh
Liz Oh Liz I
she has been everybody's girl 2019 but
like really like speaks to my heart you
were posting about her on Instagram that
was like the anthem of all of our lives
like really mine I really feel like I
take it yeah Congrats on winning the
mirror ball oh yeah where is the mirror
ball these days it's by my bed it's
still by my bed I had to what to get
home to Alabama by my bed there and you
know trying to go through the airport
with a mirror ball but like not be seen
is a really a hard thing to do its
massive it's heavy right and it's it's
sparkly and shiny and like there's
really no other thing like it so I like
to try to just get through the airport
it was hard but I did and now it's by my
bed and it's just grand old time just
getting to wake up and look at that
thing yeah we know you were filming
dancing but then we also saw you on
Peters preview for the season of The
Bachelor how much are we actually gonna
see a view I don't know I mean I feel
like we put two and two together like I
worked my ass off to win that mirror
ball so I don't know I was in the studio
8 hours a day so I don't know let's we
want to do the math on that one math and
watch in January okay yeah why did you
go back to see him there unresolved
feelings there you'll have to wait and
watch and January okay yeah yeah that's
actually all I'm gonna get yeah we are
doing an end of your piece on you and
I'm just wondering can you pinpoint the
moment that really changed your
perspective this year on life and love
[Music]
I don't know if there's just like a
moment I feel like this whole year has
really giving me opportunities to really
have to think hard about my decisions
and Who I am and what I want and up some
of those times were not so fun some of
them were amazing opportunities but I
think those hard times and those
once-in-a-lifetime experiences that I've
had have really grown me not as a woman
and as a person in a relationship to be
able to give later on and right now
that's not the case and I'm great being
just a woman on my own but for us a
single woman on your own but I mean I
really think I've grown a lot for
whenever that day comes for me I love
that
what does 2020 look like for you what do
you want to achieve and do I realized I
don't I think there's gonna be a lot of
things in store for me I mean you think
you have to manifest that but I have
realized I thought I wanted like I
wanted a break I had a break for like a
week and I hate it I think I I think I
love crazy love a crazy life I want I
want to be booked and busy so what does
that look like for you what's what's in
the store I don't want to get too much a
hint no but um I know I mean you will
see more of me hopefully more dancing oh
yeah you will in January okay I'm going
to go into work for a day in New York
and so I'll definitely dance again yeah
and that's fun that's about it I thought
that's all that I can tell it's gonna
happen yeah is there anything on the
bucket list that you would love to do oh
so I've always wanted to write a book I
want to I like being on TV so having
own TV show would be amazing talk show
like Grand Jury could this happen
I absolutely I think I could happen I've
had a lot of my bucket list things come
to me this year I mean I met Ellen not
just in the crowd like I thought I was I
was on her show for the first time the
first time I was ever on Ellen and met
Garth Brooks in backstage at the CMAs
and I just wanted to meet him in person
and I was there you know like presenting
like what is my life like it's really
been amazing so I feel like there's more
of that in store I have a feeling and
I'm gonna keep doing whatever I've got
to do to work and gain more experience
and knowledge so it's gonna be a good
2020 is gonna be my year we're putting
that out what would your book be about
by the way of my life you know just a
lot of experiences that I've had and
what I've learned and that doesn't mean
that's all like I'm not into a tell-all
like what is that like I've learned a
lot through my life and things that not
everybody knows about me and that I
haven't shared with the world and it's
my way to be able to do that in the most
authentic real way and so I think a book
would be really cool to do one day
before I let you go my last question
what do you want people to know about
you that we don't know already well
you'll have to read a book and figure
that out if whatever happens to be I
love that thank you so much
Cheers to 2020 gonna be your year
yeah thank you
[Music]